[Music]
question party is very simple
a bunch of viewers tweeted questions at
me and tarek and we're going to answer
some of them right now
ready tarek i'm ready above the law 187
asked
i don't like what your name implies
uh asked do you have any advice for
young improv performers
oh i'm starting next month and i want to
make it big like you one day but i also
know i need to start small is there
anything i should or
shouldn't do great questions
how much time do you have um
i don't know i the main thing and jenny
told me this
is you i mean it's true but you have to
remember like
the people you are on this little team
with
digging around hiring some guy to pay
him five dollars a week
to coach you like those are the people
who will have the jobs and the power to
hire you later
you know what i mean like i remember
every mother from
2002 i remember exactly what you were
like i remember what you did i remember
when you showed up late to rehearsal
yep i remember everybody remembers and
then that
will i remember your power trips i
remember
yeah yeah all of it i remember holding
your hair back while you were throwing
up on the street
now was that me or you i it was both of
us
but yeah what do you got um for me
i think so yeah uh on b just be nice but
do everything give it a shot yeah like
if someone is doing an improv rap show
and you're like oh i'm scared to do
improv rap
do it uh whatever you were scared to do
do it um and then do stuff outside of
that
don't just live in the improv world um
because you will be in an audition
it will happen above the law 187 you
will be in audition
and sitting across from you will be an
actor you've always looked up to
and you have to be there and you gotta
so like train
like do do whatever you can and then
you'll be ready
justice league asked that's a fun name
yeah
i assume their name is jessica and
they're the justice league
yeah you fun they asked what is your
favorite tv watching snack
look i'm not allowed to eat anything
anymore because
my doctor said i need to cut down on the
carbs
so i just eat freaking
garbage crap but when i go out to eat
i can have anything and that's the law
so when i'm watching tv i try to just
eat popcorn
oh nice that's a good snack yeah what's
what what's your snack and
before you say anything taric doesn't
eat anything
the answer is probably like carrots or
dust or some garbage
tarik what do you what's your favorite
tv snack well i remember the
the great dust bowl oh lord
help me clean it you know we didn't have
anything
you know what dust isn't bad it's full
of minerals no cut away from terry
you know it's a little gritty that is
all the time we have for christian party
my favorite thing about this this was
great okay
let's do it again soon all right it
feels scary yeah i get it
it feels character and you know it
really helps
your immune system because if you could
eat this well
nothing's gonna kill you
what was the question
[Applause]
you